notre témoin du 19/20 ce soir en direct
vidéo depuis ce haut lieu en côte d'or
dominique loiseau bonsoir avant
d'évoquer votre façon de vivre le
confinement une situation économique
inédite pour vous aussi le groupe
bernard loiseau ce sont donc des
restaurants saulieu on l'a dit beaune
dijon paris comment vous gérer cette
crise eh bien nous faisons au mieux vous
savez dans le groupe c'est pas la
première crise que nous avons moi j'ai
vécu la guerre du golfe en 91 voiliers
et bat tous nos établissements sont
malheureusement fermé et donc voilà
beaucoup de charges à payer on a
beaucoup de choses qui courent quand
même et on essaie de faire le dos rond
vous avez un petit peu de temps malgré
tout pendant ce confinement est ce que
vous arrivez à décompresser un petit
pour ça vous êtes toujours très présente
dans les cuisines en salle lorsqu'il ya
de l'activité
là en ce moment quand vous avez du temps
en plus on se prétend c'est au jardin
que ça se passe écoutez moi je suis
confiné dans ma maison personnelle à
saulieu j'ai la chance d'avoir un grand
jardin dont je m'occupe en temps normal
tout seul donc là j'y suis du matin
jusqu'au soir angers les chenilles large
et tout le matériel qu'il faut pour
l'embellir pour je suis un peu paysagère
vous savez que j'aime beaucoup les
jardins fed à se changer les idées
ah mais ça me vide complètement oui vous
êtes solidaires également vous avez fait
don de 800 masques ffp2 à la mairie de
saulieu les structures on a manqué aussi
dans votre secteur
oui bien sûr on a retrouvé ses masques
là qui datait de la période de la crise
du h1n1
on les a retrouvés comme cela par hasard
donc évidemment les a tout de suite
donné aux structures hospitalières de
saulieu c'est normal l'activité est
arrêtée on l'a dit mais vous allez
proposer de la vente à emporter comme le
font un certain chef pour le week-end de
pâques c'est votre restaurant de beaune
qui va concocter un menu un plat à base
d'agneau locale oui ça c'est une
initiative de de mon chef mourad
haddouche à beaune et du directeur
christophe ginès qui se sont organisés
il va y avoir une petite équipe pour
produire cela voyez ça ça monte
la motivation de certaines équipes et
qui veulent de faire de leur mieux pour
arranger leur clientèle aussi parce
qu'ils ont des clients très fidèles la
baule et je les en remercie et j'en suis
vraiment très heureuse ce sera donc pour
le week-end prochain faut réserver avant
sur le site internet ont pas cherché son
plat pour le week-end de pâques tout
simplement